the political circus underway in the U.S
has dragged into its third day now with
lawmakers appearing no closer to
electing a house Speaker Republicans
still can't even agree on a nominee
party leader Kevin McCarthy has offered
new concessions but a small group of
hard-line Republicans is standing in his
way and that has created a humiliating
deadlock with major impacts on
government operations Jackson prosco is
following the developing details Jackson
where do we stand with things now
well Sophie we haven't seen this level
of dysfunction in a speaker's race since
before the American Civil War and what
is so remarkable as this all unfolds is
that Kevin McCarthy keeps making major
concessions to his opponents and getting
nothing in return all day long he lost
vote after vote after vote by the same
margin tonight there are rumors of a
partial deal in the works behind the
scenes but so far no one has moved in
their positions the path forward is
completely unclear and big picture of
course in the long term there are
questions about damage being done here
to the Republican party's reputation
with many Americans watching the circus
and wondering if anyone is going to be
able to control this Congress and if
Republicans are going to be able to do
anything with their Newfound majority
it's going to make it more difficult for
them to accomplish anything and they
were already having the the deck stacked
against them because the Democratic
Senate and a democratic White House
would probably stymie anything they were
pushing but it's it's been a spectacle
and a disaster for the Republicans
well Jackson without a speaker can
government function
essentially no this is an important
procedural Milestone and until a speaker
is elected no member of Congress can
actually officially be sworn in and
actually start doing their jobs that
means right now they can't serve their
constituents they can't have meetings or
receive classified briefings and they
can't conduct the basic business of
government now they've only lost a few
days work so far but if this drags on
much longer it could have serious
consequences as one analyst put it to me
today thank goodness there isn't a
national emergency or War underway right
now that would require the intervention
of the house Sophie absolutely all right
thanks for that Jackson prosco in
Washington